our rachel smith joins us from nashville
hey rach
hey there guys when it comes to dressing
up no one upstages the stars of daytime
tv
especially today's hoda and jenna get my
regards to
broadway you broadway babies i tell
you wait the scary part about that song
was one you heard
jen and i sing it's not pretty let's see
[Applause]
kristen chenoweth was off in the wings
listening she said something about like
i can't ever get that
five weeks back we didn't mess one of
the words and
it didn't matter what we were saying it
turns out it just matters
how we said it well chenoweth is a
broadway icon who made glenda the good
witch famous and wicked
like a stream and both hoda and jenna's
cat's costume
are authentic from the actual broadway
musicals
jazz paul drew barrymore also took a
trip to oz as a spitting image of the
classic hollywood version of glinda the
good witch
i'm a good witch most of the time
the ladies of the talk looked pretty
sweet in the willy wonka wonderland
i always wanted to do a juice cleanse
i want to be a blueberry too
kelly and ryan held true to their
promise of more than 40 costume changes
kicking things off with joe exotic and
carol baskin
well hey there all you cool cats and
kittens a behind the scenes secrets
kelly told me she didn't even know who
some of the characters were
this got six trillion views and i go
okay so i'm the person that didn't see
this
but when it comes to the queen of
halloween
that's no doubt heidi klum looks so ugly
for the first time in 20 years heidi
won't be throwing a costume party due to
covet
but nothing will stop her from dressing
up
heidi started the transformation process
today here she is being painted to blend
into a black and white statue like
pattern
it is still anyone's guess what the
final look will be but when it comes to
her past
costumes there is still one that gives
her nightmares
the worst probably when i was
the ape and i couldn't really go to the
[Music]
bathroom
you